all right let me show you what's going
wrong
and this is a great example of remember
this right
this is where the problem is this is
where the problem is
and this is a prime example of
spreadsheet or not
where you always have to be careful when
you use a formula because formulas are
great servants but terrible masters
right if you just follow it and tell it
do whatever it tells you to do you're
going to wind up with some nonsensical
answers i wish it was this easy to get i
don't really have like anyway okay
it's not this easy to earn if it was
that easy then all like the prices would
just be up so like a chair yeah that's
right everything just inflation right so
let's fix this let's work out and fix it
i suppose the best way to work out how
to fix it to see what's wrong okay so
come with me to the top of the
spreadsheet and this will show you
what's going on okay
so double click here this is where we
started off with this volume and it was
all good everything was fine this is
principal times 1 plus the rate
to the power of how long it's in there
all good
that was one cell and then we built
everything off it but have a look at the
next cell and tell me if you can't work
out what's gone wrong
okay
now what's changed you can actually
compare it to this one right uh two
things have changed
you've got this a3 right that's the
power
that's changed from a3 to a4
yeah okay good so so i'll get there so
a4 that's good you want that to be going
up because that's the time and that
should keep on progressing that should
be this this one should point to here
three four or good okay aha but there is
a problem see this is b3 right b3
that's the that's meant to be
that's meant to be the principle the
principle that you started with namely
999
okay so as we copied our formula down
the principle also kept moving down
right so no wonder let's go down to the
bottom let's look at this this is where
he breaks the one million dollar mark
right in order to get that amount of
money that 1.8 million dollars
you actually can't start with 900 900
you've got to start with 900 000 and put
it in there for 20 years that's what'll
give you 1.8 million dollars okay so
let's fix it i'll show you how there's
lots of ways to do it but the easiest
way is like this
double click on this original cell this
one the problem cell okay
this was the issue here that b2 we
didn't want it to keep moving down we
wanted to stay
put
okay so here's the way you do it
to make this stay put
you go in there and you next in between
the b and the two you'll see why in a
second i want you to put in a dollar
sign that's above the four
like that
a dollar sign okay now that dollar sign
that's telling the spreadsheet hey see
this number see that cell
as you move keep on looking at that cell
don't move around just keep on looking
at the top one okay so you press enter
and nothing changes because that sells
phone
but now if i delete all these ones down
here the broken ones
okay wow 739 million dollars that'd be
great okay and if we replace them with
this fixed up cell so i'm going to copy
that and now i'm going to paste it down
aha reality
yes that's right this is looking a
little more reasonable thanks sad
but true okay so at least you really
know what's in your bank account rather
than some kind of illusion of millions
of dollars for free
you'll be you'll go out of here saying
mr wood told me i can just you know
okay so so there you go we fixed the
spreadsheet and when you have a look at
these numbers
these are also more reasonable you see
they are getting bigger
but they're not skyrocketing right
they're only getting a bit bigger at a
time even after decades
right
you're still not getting yeah it's true
that's true
um but 3.64 pretty humble okay maybe we
can work out a better way to do this
that's all
oh is that all you have to do right
by the way why don't we just do a quick
question okay
see this
twenty six hundred dollars right away
so you could wait twenty seven years
how old are you
here's a great question we can pose
if we go back to our original
spreadsheet suppose i'm like you fine
fine you go wait you're 27 years okay i
want to know
if i don't just sit around i wait for my
interest to do it for me
how many hours would i have to work
to get the same amount of money and not
just sit around and do something now i
know you don't want to work but i i
don't want to wait around for 27 years
okay so so hit
yes
yeah yeah yeah so here's what i want to
do
i did i did a goal seek to 999 before
yeah right
but now i'm going to do a goal seek to
this but it'll be a little different
okay so let's go back to
our wages spreadsheet this one
okay
so here's what we're gonna do
uh we worked 37 normal hours in this
week okay so i'm just going to change
that i'm going to write in the number 37
it's a bit complicated as to why
if you're curious you can ask me in five
minutes i'm just going to write as 37
all the numbers are the same okay but
now come down to this and let's do that
goal seek again which tab do i go to at
the top which one
data good
and then what we're looking for is
great what if analysis goal seek is the
one you hit okay
so again i'm going to try and change
this cell what did i want 2
600 and
something
i think it was let's just call it 30.
okay so i want to get this two and a
half grand okay
this time i'm going to change the cell
how many hours
i've worked okay so this is me thinking
okay i want to
work my way there not weight my way
there okay and by the way it's really
important it's critically important that
you change that to be the number 37 and
not just a
um not just a formula okay if you hit
enter and you haven't changed that it's
going to give you an error in a second i
can promise you i can fix it for you but
for now
let's see what happens
okay
it found a solution
you'd have to work 112
hours 112 hours now hold on we started
37 hours that's about four weeks
about four weeks that's not too bad
actually that's right i think it's
considerably better than 27 years okay
not to mention the fact that if you
waited 27 years
if you waited 27 years your
that amount of money is not going to be
worth that amount of money anymore like
you'll probably buy one tank of petrol
on that amount of money so you know
okay